welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka han yolo and this
video we're breaking down the first two
episodes of obi-wan kenobi the new
disney plus series has just dropped and
it's filled with easter eggs hidden
details and a lot of references to the
greater universe full spoilers ahead
from this point on but we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and if you want
to stay locked at the breakdowns for the
next five weeks then make sure subscribe
you do without the way thanks for
clicking this off to a good start now
let's get into obi-wan kenobi okay so
when we last saw obi-wan we were
watching him taking the moral and
literal high ground as he got rid of his
apprentice like alan sugar you blew it
you're fired
the jedi had fallen and order 66 was now
in full effect with the last remaining
jedi having to hide out in the bowels of
the universe after dropping luke off at
his aunt and uncles obi-wan left on his
eop who ends up popping up again jedi is
hiding out after order 66 and taking
menial jobs is something that was a big
focus in fall in order and in that we
watched kyle kesters hiding out whilst
the inquisitors search for the rest of
his kind inquisitors make a big entrance
in these episodes and along with the new
one river we also have some of the
classic ones like the grand inquisitor
and brother five that we'll talk about
in just a bit now we open on the planet
of course and getting introduced to some
of the younglings that ended up getting
drafted into this we see the events of
order 66 play out first hand and this
show really goes from zero to a hundred
parsecs in this space of a couple of
seconds this is jedi vaulty who defends
the children and this opening tells the
story of what i believe is the origin of
riva we learn that she is the third
sister a reckless inquisitor that
strikes first and asks questions later
but here it seems like she's just a
scared kid reading the online discourse
i've actually seen some people triggered
over this because of recent world events
and it is pretty harrowing to watch this
play out from the perspective of
children obviously the creative team
didn't know this would happen when
making this scene and taken on its own i
think this is one of the most powerful
moments in star wars history now we
discover rival later on is fixated on
kenobi but don't learn why this is
whether she might see him as being the
person that left her to fend for herself
and for also being the reason for the
creation of darth vader the man who
likely tormented her after the events of
order 66. this is a major moment in star
wars history that has been brought up
across a number of media including
fallen order clone wars and the bad
batch go to 10 years later and we find
ourselves on tatooine namely mos eisley
we can see this by the crashed ship in
the middle which you might recognize
from a new hope it's a hustling hive of
scum and villainy that reminds me of my
comment section and the black shadow of
the inquisitor ship looms overhead
shadows have been used at several points
throughout star wars films to show
dominance and here it's no different the
black ship and uniform of the inquisitor
cut out against the white desert planet
and its structure makes for a highly
contrasted image that adds a lot of
weight to their arrival now in case you
don't know inquisitors are basically
jedi hunting force sensitive soldiers
that scour the galaxy looking for the
remnants of the order they're all
extremely tragic figures and at one
point most of them were actually jedi
themselves between the events of revenge
of the sith and in new hope darth vader
built up a group of them and he enhanced
their abilities by teaching them the
ways of the dark side typically sith
always come in two with her being a
master and an apprentice with a nice
little loophole here you can actually
have as many as you want as long as you
call them inquisitors now the jedi were
of course called peacekeepers and the
inquisitors are very much a black mirror
of them keeping the peace through
oppression beyond that though the
inquisitors were assembled together
after the emperor sensed a new threat
rising and this came in the form of
children who slowly started to tap into
their abilities luke is of course on
tatooine doing this and doesn't disney's
the aging keep getting better and better
look look how good he looks now now as
for the grand inquisitor he made his
debut all the way back in the star wars
rebels premiere initially voiced by
jason isaacs he's now played by rupert
friend who's dafoe you wanna look out
for mahomey grand inquisitor is a poor
on male who actually worked as a temple
god on core ascent when the jedi order
fell vader ended up taking him under his
wing and acting like a mentor to him
though he was probably a bit of a dead
now he basically rules over all the
other inquisitors including fifth
brother sixth brother seven sister
eighth brother and ninth sister what's
terrifying about the group is that they
wield double bladed lightsabers with
circular handles that spin around
mercilessly during combat now because
the character has already popped up in
other shows and comics we know what
happens to him and he will be making it
past the events of the series i'll do
some spoilers not for this show yet but
i haven't seen it but just for his arc
in general now so if you don't want to
know what happens to him in the future
or in things like rebels or the comics
then skip ahead anyway in rebels he
managed to capture kanan jairus and ezra
and carl ended up going to save him both
kanan and bridget ended up having a
lightsaber battle with him and it
appeared that he killed them at one
point this spurred cain on to fight as
hard as he could but ezra didn't
actually die he wants more try doing the
bad on twirling technique and during
this kanan put his lightsabers in the
middle and burst up the handle which
sent the blades over the edge into the
ship's reactor this start off a chain
reaction and the inquisitor fell to his
death even though kanan did try to save
him he said that there was some fates
worse than death as he plummeted in and
in the comics we discovered that vader
trapped his soul on tempest where he was
forced to serve as a guardian for the
jedi outpost there luke battled it out
with his spirit and he won but the
inquisitor still remained behind he
asked to be freed from his tournament by
vader but he went nah chump see you
later see you chump
here they are hunting the jedi and no
one suspects the grand inquisitor no no
other people don't really like the
design especially with a pound popping
up in revenge of the sith and looking
way better but
you know you just kind of have to go
with it the guy is super intimidating
and definitely riffing on hands from
inglorious bastards we can catch the
patrons also drinking blue milk and
shout out simon a birman for pointing
out that these are in the same curves
luke had in a new hope we're told that
the jedi's compassion is their weakness
and see this in full effect when they
attempt to throw a knife at a bartender
which the jedi then stops he manages to
escape and we cut to obi-wan who's
working for a small crew cutting meat
off what i believe is a crate dragon
finn this is something we saw in the
mandalorian as well with its height
being transformed into a massive stake
like calcastas he's having to lie low
and basically do this job in order to
stay fed we watch your worker only
getting half the credits he should have
through using a gong droid as a clocking
in and out machine in the star wars
universe these are basically walking
batteries and they've always gotten
dunked on more like dunk dried a now
later on it shoots steam out of its top
which is of course playing on real world
factories now in the comics we learned a
lot about olben's time on tatooine when
luke went back to get his journals he
often put survival above being a jedi
and he let injustices happen on the
planet so long as he kept him hidden
this pulled from the comics the journals
of obi-wan kenobi which the series seems
to be based upon quite a lot we see one
of these injustices happen at this
moment as a worker's pay gets half off
like darth maul and obi-wan doesn't help
out this is long before he established a
home and obi-wan lives out in a cave
which of course represents how
ostracized the jedi are at this point a
java called chicken tikka arrives and
they say that they could smell him from
anger head which was one of the first
settlements on tatooine it was basically
a central hub for everyone and it
offered quick and easy travel to other
ports on the planet as well as ships off
world which is why bubba wanted to go
there during the first episode of his
solo show with him he's brought a t16
model which is a gift for luke who
actually ended up playing with one in a
new hope tika also brings with them the
news of the other jedi at the start and
this sets obi-wan off a bit that night
now we get moments from padme flashes of
the good and bad times with anakin yoda
and qui-gon who obi-wan attempts to
reach out to as we discovered at the end
of revenge of the sith qui-gon had
learned how to become a force ghost
which explained why only ben yoda and
anakin ended up doing it even though we
had countless jedi at one point he
doesn't appear in these first two
episodes but this could be hinting to
him coming down the line that morning we
catch a scurrier a little native
creature on tatooine that's often
confused with a womp rat you also get
the moment from the trailers with
obi-wan looking over luke and this
actually pulls directly from the comics
in which he looked over him he is of
course pretending that he's pod racing
which his father did and i love the
little reference to anakin here now joel
edgerton is playing owen laws and he's
once more reprising his role from
revenge of the sith before he was his
star in the books and this series
obi-wan knew that he should be training
luke and though this could put him in
danger it would better prepare him in
case the emperor ever found him obi-wan
knew that the temptation of the sith was
very powerful and that if he hadn't been
trained in the ways of the jedi first
that he would instantly give into it now
only the side of this was owen who he
just he just wanted a nice easy life he
just liked being
having a barbecue and getting barbecued
as well
now after obi-wan sent luke a gift owen
angrily returned it and told him the
stare of luke's life however owen did
somewhat come to appreciate him after
obi-wan saved the pair from black
crescentin you'll likely recognize him
from the book of boba fett and i think
that they purposely introduced the
character there so that it's way more
impactful when he shows up in this
series potentially might not show up but
i would love to see him in this one now
jabba had started running an extortion
at what attacks on moisture farmers in
the area and obi-wan put a stop to this
chrysanthemum was sent out by jabba to
find the man who'd cut off some of his
income and he took owen hostage to draw
obi-wan out the pair ended up fighting
each other and obi-wan won with chris
santin fleeing the planet for some time
which i think would be an awesome
storyline to drop in this series now
obi-wan ends up leaving the t-16 model
for luke that night and nary the jedi
arrives after spotting him in town
obi-wan immediately denies who he is
refusing to help and even giving the
name ben this is of course a complete
opposite to how he was with lucan and
you hope when he was like yep that's me
punk i'm the chump now he's very much
turned his back on being a jedi and he
refuses to help nary even telling him to
bury his lightsaber in the desert
similar to what ray did at the end of
rise of skywalker he says the time of
the jedi is over a line that rifts upon
luke saying that the time of the jedi
has passed in the last jedi both were
extremely broken and had basically shut
themselves off from the force
next we jump to alderaan and find out
that leia has got herself into alderaan
places are you having that now along
with the droid lola she runs through the
forest possibly foreshadowing the
training she would have later on as a
jedi with luke i have to say it's the
best i've seen alderaan looking cause oh
now leia shouts out the ships as they
pass and we get a tri-wing which is
actually a brand new ship for the star
wars universe that was designed by
porsche she also mentions the aquilan
rangers which were a group synonymous
with the rebels leia is sick of being
put on parade and owen is sick of
looking up and seeing obi-wan constantly
spying on his kid it's a bit weird
it's weird also at this moment owen
drops a really important line about how
anakin is dead at this point obi-wan
didn't actually realize that he'd become
darth vader and to him he'd just been
left cooking over what he'd become this
is a bombshell that riva drops on him
later in order to taunt him and it feels
very similar when vader was taunting
luke in return of the jedi the
inquisitors arrive once more and i have
to hand it to them they don't mess about
owen kind of voices his true feelings
about the jedi in his family who he of
course ended up looking like
i have to stop this now riva promises to
murder them if the jedi doesn't come
forward and even though we know owen
makes it to a new hope it's still a
really tense scene obi-wan refuses to
step out of the shadows and he very much
confirms that the jedi wouldn't put
themselves in harm's way in order to
help even though nari did now back on
alderaan jimmy smith is back baby and we
also see c-3po who was of course at one
point at droid that belonged to him and
his family this is confirmed by the
subtitles for the show and we also get y
o which is yo now leia's cousin is a
spoiled little
returns her for not being a true organa
but she does a character assassination
on him perhaps even using the force in
some ways to reach into his mind there
is a slight second where she seems to
sense it and later on she does this
psychoanalysis stuff on obi-wan now leia
says that she'd rather be eaten by a
jacobeast then apologize to him and
these monsters come from snow ridden
planets and are basically giant tigers
bale brings up how he wanted to chase
per gal when he was younger and these
giant space whales basically allow
characters to become the star wars
version of moby dick he says that one
day the planet will look to her which
rather than putting diplomacy above her
own feelings though she decides to run
off but trouble awaits at this point we
meet backed played by flea from the red
hot chili peppers although this chase
was goofy i did kind of enjoy these
scenes overall i think it was a smart
call to have some variety to the
surroundings rather than having us
always stuck on tatooine the organa has
reached out to obi-wan for help in the
form of a hologram which is of course a
nod delayer doing the same thing to him
in a new hope at this point we see that
nary has been captured and hung up for
the entire city to see once more obi-wan
sees himself as failing to save a young
jedi and when bale comes to him to beg
personally he decides to finally step up
he asks obi-wan to travel to daiyu which
is a neon sign laden blade runner-esque
style planet in the interviews with
entertainment weekly writer joby harold
said it's got this sort of hong kong
feel to it and it's very captivating to
look at after digging his lightsaber up
along with anakin's he ends up traveling
out to save her which we discover is a
trap set by riva need to let it go love
now i do think they heavily foreshadow
that her hunt for him will be her
downfall and it's going to be
interesting to see how it goes on daiyu
he meets a clone trooper and we see what
happened to them after the events of the
war played once more by tamira morrison
i absolutely love this cameo and
catching that he's now a homeless beggar
carries a lot of subtext with it we are
often criticized as a society for having
far too many homeless veterans and just
like us the imperials clearly didn't
look after them in the bad match we
watched first hand as the empire
realized that the price of clones was
too high to be constantly paying that
and thus they started just conscripting
citizens into their ranks they were
forced to fight which also explains why
the accuracy and efficiency of the
stormtroopers went downhill and what's a
great shot we get the all being replaced
by the new and we we meet the new guys
who are basically a downgrade now
there's a lot of talk online at the
moment that there's a cameo by mark
hamill which when i first seen it i was
like yeah definitely him however upon
inspecting it a bit closer zooming in
brightening up i'm not sure that it's
definitely him but you know the next
couple of days we'll probably find out
so if it is him then edit edit this bit
out mentally where i said it wasn't him
and add in a bit mentally where i say
this next bit it's definitely him now
having him appear would of course
massively mess up the star wars canon as
obi-wan is meant to be looking over him
as a child but either way you know it's
a nice touch if it is him he runs into a
drug dealer potentially playing on the
death stix won an attack of the clones
who was played by the same guy that was
mouse from the matrix a little kid then
comes up and offers to take him to a
jedi named hajar who has apparently been
helping people on the planet played by
kumar ninjani this guy definitely
lightens the tone of what's been a
pretty dowel run so far we quickly
discover he's not a jedi though and that
he's in fact running a con he offers a
mother and child safe passage to
corellia aka the home planet of han solo
after getting some info we get some
obi-wan beard stroking which is always
good and after he locates what i'm
guessing is a meth sorry spice lab he
dresses up like walton breaking bad and
heads in spice is a narcotic in the star
wars universe heavily based on the one
of the same name from june and lucas
admitted to taking inspiration from this
sneaking into the back he runs into two
gods one of which is a zabrak aka the
same species as darth maul
obi-wan is careful to use only his fists
and blasters on this planet as he
doesn't want to draw attention to
himself say for example if the empire
hears of someone shooting someone
they're not going to be too interested
however if they hear that someone was
struck down with a lightsaber it's a
different story and they'll send the
inquisitors there until they find the
culprit in the words of admiral akbar
it's a trap and he's caught but he
manages to escape after setting off the
spice which a walt also did that in
breaking bad to escape he finds leia in
a holding cell and we get a scene that
very much riffs on luke rescuing her in
a new hope she gives him the typical
sash she's known for that she got from
not only her mother but also i feel
anakin guy was always back chatting too
and it's nice to see how her parents
kind of formed her character hiya
riva comes and learns that kenobi is
indeed on the planet it's revealed this
is very much a power play to game favor
with vader but the rest of the
inquisitors aren't happy as she had to
kidnap leia to do it which will cause
some issues with the senate from here
the show goes very john wick and one it
adds to send out with every bounty
hunter getting a text about him we see
one that looks like a velociraptor and
this is actually a member of the race
tisha who looks similar to the dinosaur
almost everyone is after him and there's
a real tense feeling to this scene as
they try and lock down the area hunting
him in leia as he moves through the
shadows also can we get a shout out to
hong kang who plays fifth brother in the
show guy also plays han in fast and the
furious and it really makes me want to
get justice for han solo also leia is
placed in a green coat which i think is
meant to look similar to the overall
that you are on indoor after sprinting
off we get a similar scene to when omega
left in the bad batch and she races
throughout the city which is when
everyone starts to close in i believe
one of these is a member of the pike
clan who we had run-ins with in the
clone wars the bad batch solo and book
of boba fett river does some parkour as
she chases after the pair on rooftops
whilst they're fired up by the tisha cha
to shah
alaya ends up falling but obi-wan
reaches inside himself and finally he
embraces the force once more and saves
her life hija ends up redeeming himself
too and we discover that he got the
family safe and just wants to help the
jedi it shows how the jedi are very much
a force for good that inspired people
throughout the galaxy and you know their
removal it just made morale dip across
the entire universe or galaxy i was
getting trouble saying universe i'll
just i'll just say galaxy again now he
ends up using his performance skills to
buy time and riva dives into his mind
much like how we saw kylo ren doing it
in the force awakens the grand
inquisitor kills veck whilst doing his
thanos helicopter move and river tracks
the pair to the cargo bay we actually
see obi-wan hiding out which is a major
change-up for the character this is a
guy that just jumped headfirst into
fighting general grievous and it's wild
seeing him scared for once saved by the
bell and the grand inquisitor arrives as
riva almost gets to him she ends up
stabbing him but as we've already talked
about he does survive this in the cannon
and likely won't be too happy that he
got back well front stabbed now we end
with vader waking up in his back to tank
and what a way to reveal the character
hopefully we don't get 20 flashbacks
whilst he's in this next time but it's
such a cool way to close out these first
two entries anyway that's the two
episodes and you will leave your
thoughts on the show in the comments
below doing like doing like a hand
movement you can't see if i'm doing a
hand movement now you're in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episodes
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now save that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some meals to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the thor trailer which will
be linked on screen right now going over
some of the easter eggs in it talking
about the characters and if you're into
that movie then you need to get into
that video if not then thanks for
sending through this one i've been paul
and i hope to see you next week take
care peace